Aww Yeah! Today, we'll learn English vocabulary and pronunciation with the classic animated movie, Ice Age!
I'm Andrea, and every week here on Learn English with TV series,
we help to teach you fast English without getting lost, without missing the jokes, and without subtitles!
Just like Somiya, who says that our channel has helped to give her so much more confidence when talking in English!
So don't forget to hit that subscribe button and the bell down below
so that you don't miss any of our new lessons!
Are you frustrated by still not understanding fast English?
Then our Fluent with Friends course would be perfect for you!
In this 48-week course, you will learn in a fun way with the first two seasons of Friends!
You'll receive PDF Power Lessons every week,
vocabulary memorization software, access to our Fluency Circle global community, and so much more!
The best part is you can try it right now for FREEwith our 3-part Masterclass!
All you have to do is click this link, or in the description box below to learn more and sign up now!
We really hope to see you there!
If you're enjoying this lesson,
then I highly recommend that you watch our lesson on Finding Nemo, where you can learn even more vocabulary
grammar and pronunciation.
All you have to do is click this link, or in the description box below to watch it straight after this lesson!